OUR ECONOMY IS GOING TO BE A BIG
QUESTION BUT I THINK WE ARE UP
TO IT.
>> Dana: AND STILL, THE 2020
ELECTION IS HAPPENING.
YOU WROTE TODAY ABOUT FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN LIKELY
TO BE THE CANDIDATE.
BUT WHAT SORT OF STRATEGY WILL
HE DEPLOY IN ALL THIS?
THE IDEA THAT HE WOULD CALL
TRUMP TO TRY TO MAKE SOME SORT
OF DEAL OR AGREEMENTS, IS THERE
ANY APPETITE FOR THAT RIGHT NOW?
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS INTERESTING.
THE PRESIDENT WAS ASKED IF HE
WOULD TAKE A CALL FROM BIDEN AND
HE SAID YES.
AND PEOPLE IMMEDIATELY SAID THEY
WERE GOING TO TRY TO SET UP SUCH
A CALL.
I THOUGHT IT WAS INTERESTING
BIDEN’S CAMPAIGN RESPONSE.
THIS IS WHAT HIS SPOKESMAN SAID.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN SLOW AND
CHAOTIC IN HIS RESPONSE.
HE SPENT MONTHS DISREGARDING
REPEATED WARNINGS FROM HIS
HEALTH AND SCIENCE ADVISORS.
I WOULD LIKE TO HEAR WHAT
DR. FELT SHE HAS TO SAY ABOUT
THAT.
COULD HAVE HEATED BIDEN’S PUBLIC
ADVICE NOT TO TAKE THE CHINESE
AT THEIR WORD BUT DIDN’T HE CALL
THE BAN ON CHINA TRAVEL RACIST
AND HYPERSENSITIVE?
THE NEXT ONE WAS, WE HAVE MORE
CASES THAN ANY OTHER COUNTRY IN
THE WORLD.
WAIT A MINUTE, THAT’S TAKING
CHINA AT ITS WORD.
WE HAVE MORE CASES THAN CHINA
BUT THAT’S THE OFFICIAL NUMBER.
THE UNOFFICIAL NUMBER MAY BE AS
MANY AS TEN TIMES THE 85,000
THAT THEY CLAIM, THE CASES THAT
THEY’VE HAD.
THIS IS NOT A GOOD WAY TO SORT
OF SET IT UP.
IT WAS LIKE THE PRESIDENT MADE A
GOOD-FAITH EFFORT.
I’D BE HAPPY TO TAKE HIS CALL
AND THE IMMEDIATE RESPONSE TO
THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN WAS THE KIND
OF SHRILL HYPER PARTISANSHIP
WHICH IS WHAT THE COUNTRY
DOESN’T WANT.
RIGHT NOW THE COUNTRY WANTS
UNITY AND LESS PARTISANSHIP AND
THAT COMMENT FROM THE BIDEN
CAMPAIGN WAS PARTICULARLY
TONE-DEAF AS MANY OF HIS
COMMENTS IN RECENT DAYS HAVE
BEEN.
THE ACCUSATIONS THAT HE HAS BEEN
THROWING THAT HAVE BEEN WILD,
THE DECLARATIONS THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP OUGHT TO LISTEN
TO DR. FAUCI AND DR. BROOKS AND
THAT IS AFTER WE SAW THE
PRESIDENT STANDING ALONGSIDE